so much stuff is said about you that
because you're so banned you can't
respond to and this is like the craziest
thing because I'll watch something and
I'll go Alex should be on his show
refuting that and I know you are but
it's not anywhere that anybody can see
and one of the things that I watched was
at January 6th I watched you tell the
protesters to not enter the capital to
be peaceful he said we're not antifa
we're not going to burn things down this
is what they want we're not going to
give it to them that has never been
played on mainstream media they have
never played any video footage of you
telling protesters to not breach the
capital which is literally what happened
and I want to play that clip in a minute
speaking to you off air a lot of things
are now
coming out about January 6th they
changed the picture a little bit from
what people thought was that was just a
little bit just a little bit and I want
to know if you can illustrate some of
that for us because I know that this
directly impacts you it affects you
um uh you were there you were there to
protest what you felt was uh uh a sham
election anomalies yes right election
anomalies you were not there to breach
the capital and you were telling your
supporters to not reach the capital but
there were people in the crowd
encouraging violent Behavior agitating
leading and now it's coming out that
some of those people are from an
interesting origin
absolutely and I mean it's a giant story
and it's bigger than January 6 for Trump
or any of that with your love never had
him you know I've got a lovely
relationship with him it's that we had a
million people with the ellipse for his
rally on the six then they said Alex
lead a March down there well the
hundreds of thousands already under the
capitol before I ever got in the middle
of it I said how do I lead this so I was
telling the crowd be peaceful it's a big
crowd but all our other rallies been
peaceful and we get down there and tear
gas is already getting fired and all
this stuff's happening and I didn't know
that out of a million people and
hundreds of thousands with the capital
that a few hundred attack police and
broke in
and I was up there saying stop it don't
go in and then the Wall Street Journal
the New York Times by that afternoon
said Alex Jones was there leading the
attack saying attack the capital even
though we had the video but it was only
on infowars.com right it was only on
bandop video no one else outside of our
footage could see that and know that
since then it's got it on Twitter and
gotten tens of millions of views of us
they're getting huge amounts of people
that have been the doors have been
opened once they broke through waving
people back and keeping people from
going in then I got subpoenaed I got
deposed by the January 6 committee uh
they were trying to indict me they did
arrest Owen Troyer and my camera guy
San Mateo that were there with me being
totally peaceful yeah
but I was too well known I was the guy
up there loud saying don't go in
but they were with me so the feds when
they arrested them indicted them and
they're still facing trial uh my guys
have done a plea bargain yes their
trials are coming up they said Owen
Shroyer broke into the capital and
attacked people right he was with me he
was trying to stop it right so so when
you see them filing in court things like
saying the Loch Ness monster you know is
is is is our president or the Easter
Bunny you know is real you're like it's
next level when you're experiencing
things that are totally fraudulent but
because you're banned on all the major
platforms you can't respond they have a
blank check so censorship isn't just
about silencing people you can then
steal their identity right and you can
then say whatever you want in their
voice or take things out of context and
that's what's so dangerous about
censorship but now we have Matt tabe and
the Twitter file is a great job Elon
Musk and all of it coming out that
agencies and governments and big Tech
with media we're working in coordination
to surveil what people are saying that
have been censoring millions of people
for years including during the Trump
Administration so that's all coming out
I know you you were telling me before I
went live here or before you turned down
came in the show that you've got some of
those clips but this is just an amazing
moment to be alive plus they've got the
proud boys trial going on in D.C and
just a few days ago it began to break
they've had Federal followings I've got
copies of we can do an overhead shot
here maybe of your guys punch it up
where the feds accidentally gave a bunch
of files to the defense with stuff like
we've been ordered to delete 300 plus
files we've been ordered to cover up
they were non-violent we've been ordered
now they're declaring today National
Security in D.C saying these are top
secret documents so they are in full
remember the Whitmer kidnapping plot
where it turned out the feds again
accidentally handed over stuff they
wanted to cover up yeah and it was them
ordering you know like these potheads to
attack Whitmer and they were like I
don't want to oh can I have money for a
Big Mac right can I have a dime bag of
weed it's in the recordings right and
they never attacked the lady yeah the
first group got off but the second time
the judge covered it up they all got
convicted so the point is the fit the
same group that led the attack on
Whitmer that never happened were
intimately involved the same unit of the
FBI in January 6. that's not coming I
mean look at this these are documents
that are now being there National
Security uh are they classified are they
just today the judge is declaring them
classified uh but this is the federal
filing so I won't show the classified
doctors I'll show the federal filing in
here uh that's now been put up by uh
a bunch of even mainstream
journalists like Julie Kelly it says
right here edit out they were present
that the feds were there leading the
group and then it describes in one line
uh here and I guess the crew could
probably pull this up where they say
here it is
Miller's Communications with other agent
who states the agent's FBI boss assigned
to 338 items of evidence I had to
destroy why would they want to do that
destroying evidence is a felony why
would they want to destroy the evidence
wouldn't they want more evidence well
good because they were leading it of
course yeah well and that's why they're
trying to block Tucker releasing their
raw footage and on Tuesday and you see
these videos of people opening doors
allowing people in the capital there's a
video of the Q Anon Shaman guy with the
the [__] hat with the horns she's
being led around the Capitol by multiple
police opening doors and led into the
center chamber yeah and he thought he
was with Q he thought they were with him
and this was a coup right I had him on
two days after he's like no the police
were women they let me in we're winning
we're taking over and I said no dude
you've been set up right and I felt so
sorry for him now four years in prison
yeah non-violent turns out he's
schizophrenic right he's kicked out of
the Navy for being schizophrenic I've
talked to this family people that know
him really nice guy non-violent yeah and
they've now
framed a schizophrenic as the leader of
a mastermind operation can we play the
clip of Alex's War where we have Alex
with a bullhorn on January 6th telling
people to not be violent because this by
the way will be the first time a lot of
people have seen this on a public
platform because it is you telling the
protesters at January 6 to not engage I
was about to say you're sticking your
neck out here because yeah the only
place until Elon muskok over Twitter
this was allowed nowhere right I mean
this is I mean obviously I don't want to
attack the capital I don't want to go to
jail what does that makes it look like
idiots right and but they're trying to
say I'm no I showed up the middle of it
was like what the hell don't go in well
I was watching it with friends at my
house and I was going I I turned to a
friend of mine I said this is [__]
absurd that there's a video of you
telling people not to attack the capital
that has never been seen to my knowledge
by anybody really and this again is you
telling people we're not antifa we don't
want to burn [__] down we don't want to
breach the capital we want to be
peaceful and make our voices heard and
it it throws the whole narrative about
you about the you know what they're
calling obviously the riot
um into question and I've never seen
I've been uh conscious human being for I
don't know 25 years maybe and it's
shocking to me how quickly this stuff is
debunked now things would happen it
would take years but JFK it took years
people writing books and going to
libraries and looking up articles and
you know hurting their eyes squinting at
these little pieces of paper now within
a matter of weeks and months all of
these narratives are collapsing
and and that's what scares me I'll be
honest it does scare me that
I can't get this out anywhere obviously
I don't want to attack the capital we
wanted to protest and have a 10-day
Senate investigation I showed up tear
gas literally hit me from 200 yards away
uh people were climbing scaffolding I
saw Riot police they were attacking
police I'm like no no no don't do it
then I went to the police and I said I
know you have a loud speaker system they
use it that night super loud like the
voice of God leave the capitol you're
not allowed to be here I went to the
police they got a captain I said it's on
video yeah it's on our uh on uh my
security had you know the cop cams the
what do you call those body cams body
cams and I say look I know you have this
loudspeaker system it's the voice of God
which is by seven o'clock at night leave
earlier martial law do not be here I
mean it's like I am us I mean it's super
[__] 5000 DB yeah and they said we
later learned they were their commanders
would not respond for four hours yeah so
they were actually saying give us the PA
system what I was saying yeah and they
were just ordered to stand there with
their thumbs in their asses so I don't
blame the cops and you know no cops died
that day one guy died of a stroke the
next day the cops did get attacked it
was wrong five citizens died have you
heard that there are suicides with the
Capitol Police yeah that's what happened
that's when the the few that died later
were suicides and one was a stroke okay
but but my issue is the attorney general
the U.S two days ago came out and said
five officers were murdered that day
Tucker Carlson was lying about the five
officers in fact I know your crew's in
there guys find that clip yeah like 15
seconds
everybody knows now that nobody died
that day but five citizens right so
Ashley Babbitt and others so they're
still that's what I'm saying they're
saying five officers died that day it's
on record they didn't like right why are
they so confident to lie like that well
because I think the reality is a lot of
people aren't paying attention a lot of
people don't have access to the
information right A lot of people aren't
going to that's what they're counting on
they're counting on that they they count
on that I was looking at it I've now
watched a lot of that footage I've
watched it on planes when they're about
to take off I've watched it when I'm in
hotel rooms on the road doing comedy and
I'm going something doesn't make sense
something's off you're telling people do
not attack it's gotten completely away
from you there are people that are being
led into this building by it looks like
uniformed Capital police a hundreds they
sent more than half the police away for
crowd control the ellipse Mile and
halfway right by the White House which
one was giving a speech so you
you get there there's like 50 cops yeah
for I mean it's like a football game a
championship or a basketball game
there's a million people there in the
town 100 000 of the stadium a few
hundred Riot you don't blame the whole
stadium so a few hundred did attack the
police who tear gas them the police
didn't have the numbers they needed they
got attacked they did get beat up it was
wrong people like Ray apps are ramming
signs into them saying go into the
building but he doesn't get in any
trouble and by the way he told the
January 6th commission under oath I
orchestrated the attack on the capitol
why is he not indicted but my co-host
Owens Troyer s well there's a lot of
people that behaved poorly clearly
there's a lot of people that got excited
agitated angry they they did not
psychology mob psychology they didn't
act like a responsible citizen they
didn't do what you asked them to do but
then you also have documents coming out
right now saying that this thing
potentially you know or maybe definitely
was led by
Federal informants federal agents well I
mean I I know people at the highest
levels of The Proud boys trial
and I've
I have the federal filing around here
but it yeah this is the beauty of the
universe yeah
they literally handed over the secret
files of the FBI they thought they
deleted it was an attached file and it's
all how they had informants in the proud
boys the informants said they're not
violent right that uh famous Stewart
Rhodes oath keeper Enrique tario meeting
on January 5th in the parking garage
they were talking about defending people
protecting against antifa the informants
are like there was no talk of this
they're they're saying delete the
evidence of the informants from The
Trial so they can't find a lot of
evidence of a pre-planned insurrection
like a pre-planned Riot a plea a
pre-planned interaction like they don't
have evidence of these people conspiring
to do this no okay
and so instead they cherry pick what the
informants say and edit out like 90 of
it right and then use it and then so the
judge says well we can't tell you the
informants are but here's what they said
and then it's an edited thing the
informant said right when you're there
are you feeling A vibe that something's
off something's getting away from you I
mean I mean I mean let me recount that
morning yeah I mean I'll just give you a
straight up account
I get up at 7am hungover in a suite at
the Willard Hotel where I've been doing
interviews the whole night before
we ordered breakfast we drink coffee I
have sex with my wife and uh
I say I got a hangover
let's order a bottle of whiskey
so we get like a small bottle of whiskey
we drink it with coffee my wife goes I
just want to stay here I don't want to
go to this I'm exhausted I Say No baby
let's go so we walk outside the wheels
let's try with the ellipse and it
literally takes us an hour and a half
with like 15 security like a mosh pit to
battle through these crowds and get the
so-called VIP Lane to go in because
there's a million people outside and
forty thousand right there so there's
actually a million people at this event
the whole the ellipse the monument it's
just but only forty thousand you can get
in the actual Court in the apartment
Secret Service where Trump's speaking so
it's all surrounding people who can't
get in we have to fight through all that
get in I'm sitting here going down that
Whiskey's wearing off and and so we
finally get through like a mosh pit I'm
exhausted my wife's like I want to go
home I don't like this Roger Stone's
calling me saying I don't like this I
can get into the crowd I'm going home
blah blah it's a [__] and I sit
down for like three hours of Republicans
giving boring speeches and my wife's
like my feet are freezing off honey
let's just go back to the hotel and take
a hot bath uh you know and her instincts
like I have a bad feeling she literally
says let me just let's go back to the
hotel I'll suck a dick let's just I'm
being honest this is what's up she goes
baby let's just go eat food which would
have been hindsight been the better plan
no I mean she actually said this yeah
yeah and she's never women's instincts
like yeah I don't like this I don't like
this I want to go I don't want to go to
the Capitol not my baby shut up and
finally Trump comes out we're watching
all the Republicans peacock behind the
stage we're in the front row all this
stuff's going on
and
then the Secret Service these people
these feds where they go Mr Jones Trump
wants you to lead the March 30 minutes
before he's done we will open the gate
you will go out to Pennsylvania Avenue
lead to March and I'm sitting there and
I'm already watching crowds that are
tired of sitting around us hitting there
in trouble speeding led by antifa led by
the feds led by all this they're already
all marching down towards the Capitol
and I'm going how do I was a bullhorn
does my crew my Security's waiting
outside born right I go how do I leave
they go Trump will be there don't worry
it's all a setup not by Trump by the way
so finally they open the gate in the
front stage Trump's still speaking I'm
like Trump's like 30 feet away right
around the side I walk around and I'm in
the back of the stage and I'm with all
these Republicans and I go I didn't go
to the bathroom and the FEDS are like no
Mr Jones you got to go right now
meanwhile they were they were timing me
to be there right with the breach out
and I go no I gotta go to the bathroom
my wife said yeah I gotta go to the
bathroom
my wife's like I'm leaving honey my feet
are hurting it's so cold out here I
didn't know I wore the wrong shoes I go
baby you go back to the hotel I'll find
out what's going on I don't think I can
even leave this March I'll see you
she leaves uh with the lady she was with
so one of the event organizers so I go
in the bathroom take care of things get
out I'm on Pennsylvania Avenue already
like hundreds of thousands are Marching
and I go how am I supposed to leave this
I go this needs to be peaceful because
people are like if you we're gonna you
know so I get up on one of the platforms
of these big planners like 20 feet above
the roads so I got this big tree planter
and I go be peaceful this is all on
video yeah be peaceful people play that
right now because that's the video I
want people to see if we the only reason
I'm taking time is yeah yeah this is the
whole I mean I'm being honest like I
drink whiskey I bang my wife right I I
you know a a freaking Scrambler right I
mean this is like what happened yeah and
then what happens when I get there is
more insane yeah go ahead play the club
let's play the clip
[Music]
you're amazing I love you let's March
around to the other side
and let's not fight the police and give
the system what they want
we are peaceful
now we won this election
and as much as I love seeing the Trump
flags flying over yes
we need to not have the confrontation
with the police they're going to make
that the story
Army on a March to the other side when
we have a stage where we can speak and
occupy peacefully
tell everybody behind you march to the
other side March to the other side
order
you guys are great but the police
depositors have caused a problem and the
police are throwing trash things we
don't want to have a kid stay here
so I love you or saving the Republic
this is beautiful but please tell
everyone to go March every other side
you always start to make a password back
over here
on the other side
so Mark will ask us
[Music]
so this is you know again it's kind of
irrefutable you're there you're telling
people not to breach the capital you're
starting to say you're you're saying to
stay peaceful obviously it's not working
because there's people that are like
completely most of them can't even hear
me I mean like the boulevard goes maybe
100 yards but what I'm saying is the
timeline is that you're giving me an
opportunity with your huge audience I
don't know so I'm a mile and a half from
the ellipse and I'm like how do I lead a
crowd and Trump's because we had a we
had permitted
by the Supreme Courts right here the
capital's here so in between the Supreme
Court the capitol we had a big stage and
Trump was thinking he was coming there
yeah but Trump was set up too
so I'm like BPS will be peaceful that's
another video
20 minutes before I get there then I get
there people are climbing the
scaffolding there's tear gas I see
people falling off parapits I'm like I'm
in a medieval war right and I'm like I
better get up on this pile of chairs
they weren't even unfolded like a stack
of chairs boxed you know with plastic on
them for like the a month from then or a
few weeks from then for the inauguration
so I climb all the time and say don't go
in we got a lot of people not to go in
because the feds had the police had
opened the doors under orders not
blaming them they were ordered to do it
and and and and so then
I go let's go the other stage so I go
around I talk to the police captains and
people I wait for like 10 minutes to
talk to them I go you got to get on your
loudspeakers you got to say get out of
the Capitol and then they wouldn't talk
they said we can't talk to you we just
and I said well what can I do they said
why don't you go up on the other side
they're trying to break the door in most
people are just standing there you know
talking but like a few people are
attacking the door they said why don't
you go up there and try to get them out
the door so I go up I say get out of
here come down it's so noisy there's all
these people blaring other bull horns
they can't hear me I looked at my crew
and I could see guys with machine guns
assault Rivals pouring in feds and I
said I need to go home to my children
let's leave right now and I and I
marched to the crowd saying leave leave
leave a lot of folks listen to me and a
lot of them left but it was then
learning in hindsight how they had 500
paramilitary police dressed as civilians
with with guns how they had hundreds of
FBI informants and now we know FBI
informants were leading the attack with
the CIA it's coming on court on the
building so we're going to find out if
these documents are ever made public
that there is proof that there is FBI
and CIA kind of collusion with people
that are on the ground leading them into
their Capital yeah if anything
Republicans are too pro-war and to Pro
State yeah but when do Republicans
attack police and Terror buildings right
it doesn't happen right uh we got
provocateured into it yeah and thank God
because I could see the timing not all
the secret service but definitely the
groups involved yeah because most of
Trump's White House is run about deep
state by then most of the people are
resigned so he only got deep there are
people there are people no doubt that
were caught up in the fervor and did the
wrong thing yes in the mob Madness for
sure but but but we now know this is
what you said that's what's interesting
right you weren't saying that you were
not directing it so if you're not
directing it and the proud boy Oath
Keepers if they don't have the proof
that they're directing it who's
directing it that's the question well
rayap said he said he orchestrated it
who is that
um he was there for days on all the
dozens of videos saying attacked the
capital tomorrow he was there with
ramming with sign up with the police he
was commanding everybody yeah you see
him give orders like he'll be in the
crowd because they're not releasing this
footage yeah he'd be in the crowd this
was a tiger was gonna do on Tuesday but
they stopped it and he would go and like
mechanized troops would come in like
military in in Trump outfits and he
would go Red Zone attack right and they
were just like boom like like Felix
Roman soldiers attack yeah and so and
they get this giant Trump sign and
ramming over the police and then Grandma
adores the goal is this is clearly to
present the idea that anybody on that
side is completely unreasonable violent
and a terrorist well that's it and take
a John Wayne movie that are based on
real bar fights I've been a lot of bar
fights but I've been in two somebody
punches somebody it starts nobody knows
everybody starts fighting and it was
like that once you ram over the police
once they tear gas and once the crowd
kind of gets in a fight most of the
drivers trying to stop him there's a
million people or hundreds of thousands
were there million in the town they pour
in then the feds open the doors right
and so that's what happened